so our first question from anthony impe
of optimity
should the uk be investing in hs2 when
the country's broadband infrastructure
is so bad and letting down small and
medium-sized businesses and stopping
them growing and competing in the global
economy
well i think we need both we need um the
highest quality transport network that
we can get but also we can't compete
unless we complete the broadband
challenge and we're not there and we're
getting behind on getting to 100
broadband on hs2 i've been clear and
labour's been clear we'll support the um
the plan the first stage to crew going
through the commons at the moment
there's a debate about getting the best
route for the second phase but the
important thing it's got to be value for
money we've got to keep the costs under
control i've been clear there's no blank
check for me we will go ahead on the
basis that the sums add up and its value
for money but but uh on broadband we
can't afford to fall behind and we are
at the moment yeah you had a bit of a
wobble on hs2 a year ago is it fair to
say shadow chancellor you weren't
entirely convinced i said there's no
bank check and at that time the costs
were going up billions by billions by
billions and the government has tried to
get a grip on the costs and they've made
some progress but on the second phase i
think there's been too much focus on
only linking manchester and the north to
london we've also got to think about
hull to liverpool the connections east
to west are just as important the
chancellor says he wants to have high
speed 3
after high speed 2 but why should we
wait to connect across the north for 10
20 30 years we should get on and do that
as soon as we can in my view and